worst food move of all time picking up a
hamburger you drop on the floor at
laguardia worst
free agent signings of all time today's
draft here's the trivia question for you
chris laguardia airport is named after a
former
new york city mayor what was his first
name and
mayer is not the correct answer yeah i
know may or
mister uh i mean i i've seen
i can picture the little never gonna get
it you're never gonna get it
it's a crazy name i wanna say frank i
don't know why
frank laguardia
[Music]
should we give it to him he's got he's
got two of the letters
is it fiorello it starts with an f it's
arsenal and f though or no
yeah gosh because i know i've seen the
plaque in the airport
many times but okay frank is my answer
i'm wrong so go ahead
see i uh i would have thought i would
have thought it was vincent because
the name of joe pesci's character and my
cousin vinnie was vincent laguardia
gambini so
i wouldn't have thought of anything
other than vincent okay i get the first
pick
albert hainsworth final answer um
disaster
of a free agent signing 100 million
dollar contract that was finalized just
a few hours after free agency began in
2009 that was when free agency started
when the negotiation period opened it
was all one thing and there was clearly
tampering there was actually a tampering
investigation of washington because chad
speck
who represented albert hainesworth was
spotted having dinner with daniel
schneider at the combine
and the excuse was they were talking
about malcolm kelly and how
the guy who ended up being a bust of a
receiver could be the next andre johnson
no they were talking about albert
haynesworth
he got a bunch of money it was a
disaster once
mike shanahan got there and it was it
was it was never
it never worked for albert haynesworth
and washington
and uh he was supposed to get 40 million
guaranteed he never even got that it was
just it was a bad scene all around
and uh the worst in my opinion free
agent signing of all time
no it's up there you know what what's
crazy i got a
little personal experience with albert
right i mean first off me and albert
went on our visit to the university of
tennessee together
uh so we spent that weekend together
right and my aunt wendy
you know who watches the show
religiously she always loved her some
albert hainesworth because of that
he was mike when i was in tennessee
he was the best even supplier in the nfl
and he was leading up to that
he is totally a guy and i don't think
he'd have any problem with me
saying this he chalked it up once he got
the cash there's just no doubt
he talked about cash a lot i still
thought he'd have more success than he
did in washington he was unblockable
he was unbelievable for the tennessee
titans during those days but
uh yeah that that was a bad one all
right um
i think i'm going to start off with
larry brown i mean
larry brown got a i don't even remember
the money and i don't have the details
here
but he got all he got a bunch of money
from the oakland raiders
you know a few months after he had those
two interceptions in super bowl 30
and he never even really played for the
raiders they spent all this money acting
like it was a big time free agent
acquisition
and it's like they signed them all
because of one game it was kind of crazy
uh i mean the raiders actually did it as
i was looking at this before did it
twice they did it in the next year with
desmond howard
uh which was odd but to me that that
will go down as one of the worst free
agent signings of all time just because
it was awful one game and they got
nothing uh in return off of that
five years twelve and a half million
with three and a half million guaranteed
february 20 1996 when he signed with the
raiders
that was a lot of of cash at the time
uh yeah now it's just a not even a
mid-level deal
as nfl goes but that's because the
salary cap keeps going up and up and up
back in those days it was probably
47 50 52 million dollars for the salary
cap for the entirety of your roster
next one for me man there's a lot of
there's a lot of ones here i know uh
hmm there's some recent ones where i'm
like
man you know we want to think of the old
ones but there's some recent ones
i'm gonna go scott mitchell okay scott
mitchell was the guy who stepped in 93
when dan marino ruptured an achilles
tendon on contact
went to the detroit lions and was what
you did
just you know got big money and never
lived up to it and he was supposed to be
the savior for the lions when you have
barry sanders as your running back come
on you need to be a little bit better
than scott mitchell was so i just think
that was
way too much money for a guy who never
panned out for the line you're right i
mean i remember at the time just going
whoa they're paying him that
like you know i know there were some
good moments and some big yardage games
and everything like that but
they paid him like he was a nfl
superstar
and certainly was not proven to be that
yet that that i i can still remember
that day
you know i think i'm in high school
early years of high school when that
happened
um the next one man i got so many too
i'm gonna go to this one this is an
under the radar one
and it's not necessarily about all the
big money but elvis gerbach
with the baltimore ravens that was the
stupidest crap ever
i don't know what to say you win the
super bowl with trent dilfer
and you don't run it back like trent
dilfer's got to be pissed about that to
this day
sorry manchester but yeah he's got to be
mad about that low and like wait
i know we didn't set the world on fire
but he made some big throws in the
playoff games
you know afc championship super bowl i
was sitting there when they were playing
the giants he did some things there
how do you not run that back then they
give they give gerbac a big payday
and he threw more interceptions than
touchdowns the next year so to me that's
one of the dumber free agent signings in
the history of football
yeah that one you know what that's a
good one that that one was
uh uh a very very bad one for the ravens
and to push out a guy who did lead you
to a super bowl championship even though
he wasn't a guy who was a gunslinger you
you give up your stability and your
continuity and you run the risk that uh
it's going to end up being a problem all
right
um man i hate to do it i hate to do it i
hate to do it
uh-oh oh yes i hear you i was on my list
four years 88 million dollars what i
remember the the eagles
were trying to pull off the franchise
tag and trade until they realized
no one was going to trade for the
franchise tag amount
and then do a long-term contract based
on the franchise tag amount but still
22 million a year for folsom i i was
just i was
look i i thought he had done enough to
deserve his opportunity
yeah and yeah he broke a collarbone week
one
throwing a touchdown pass against the
chiefs but it
we saw him get an opportunity last year
in chicago he's just not built to be a
starter he's built to be the guy
who comes in and pulls the bacon out of
the fire that's right when the starter
gets injured that's it
yeah he's a guy that needs real support
not to say he's a system guy but you
know he needs a certain formula
around him to what you're saying and
going to jacksonville where a team
you know was not that great and
everything like that
that's not the situation he's gonna
thrive in just not
you know it's it's oh okay i got a team
okay i can run the offense and take
what's there to be had and
and do all that that's good oh wait you
need to carry me to carry the team
oh crapola i can't do that i mean that's
what we saw we saw mitchell trubisky was
better at doing that with the bears than
the nick foles was so i'm with you
that's a head scratcher for sure
um well i'll see
your nick falls and i'll crush it with
brock osweiler to the texans
what what what the hell
was that i love billy o'brien i really
do i got a lot of respect for him
that was the dumbest move he made as
well he wasn't even the gm at that time
but that was the dumbest move the texans
made
uh during that that for brock osweiler
why because he was on a team that went
to the super bowl and he didn't even
play in the game
i mean that was insane four years 72
million
and of course compound that by what did
they have to do give the browns was it
gave up a second round pick they gave up
a second round pick to get
to get rid of your guaranteed contract
off the roster in the second
i mean holy crap bola let's give 72
million dollars to a quarterback who
can't really throw the football
what i still cannot i this is
like branded into my brain forever super
bowl 50
the pregame hey peyton's on his last leg
we know that
peyton's one of the greatest of all time
i'm not trying to take a shot here
but him and brock osweiler and pre-game
warm-ups
was one of the most underwhelming
pregame warm-ups i've ever seen in my
life
and i'm talking about college nfl
whatever i know i never saw more
receivers
dropping to the knees going down to the
ground to catch balls
with nobody on defense like curl routes
that you ran in eighth grade
and guys are like whoa i gotta get down
and pick this off i mean it was it was
pitiful but
that that's a crazy one to me others
that i had on the list neil o'donnell
david boston right desmond howard you
mentioned him
dexter jackson who was the mvp of super
bowl 37
shouldn't have been he got a big
contract from cincinnati i believe after
that
we mentioned alvin harper earlier
le'veon bell recently that was
dumb namdae assamwa right that's another
one i'm the awesome osmo
adelius thomas the patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports